i want to bring in dr simmering please
[Music]
all right good afternoon ladies and
gentlemen please be seated
we are ready to resume the
cross-examination of dr simmering
go ahead mr shellhorn thank you your
honor
good afternoon doctor
good
i afternoon we left off uh before the
lunch break i was going to ask you some
questions about your testimony on direct
examination related to
guns
and i think you had indicated on direct
examination that you were aware from mr
barrisson telling you that there were
certain posts or social media
references to lauren cantarak owning
guns yes
and he told you that he was aware of
that before the shooting yes
and i think you had indicated that that
was part of what you relied on
uh in rendering your opinion or forming
your opinion that he was delusional at
the time of the shooting
that he believed a lot of this and all
this led into delusional thinking
now you were aware from your review of
the discovery that mr barristone had
called 9-1-1 on a number of occasions
leading up to the day of the shooting
yes at least four occasions do you
recall did you listen to any of those
911 recordings i did
do you recall on the july 31st 911 call
when he was asked whether any weapons
were involved or mentioned and his
response was no that's correct
and you recall on august 1st when he
called 9-1-1
he was asked if weapons were involved or
mentioned and his response was no i
believe that as i recall that was true
and on august 3rd do you recall that he
called 9-1-1 and was asked if weapons
were involved or mentioned
and his response was i have not heard a
word of that
something like that yes those are
standard questions and i believe he
answered in the negative
and lastly on august 5th on the call he
was asked if weapons were involved or
mentioned and his response was
not so far that's correct not so far
that's correct
now
doctor i think you testified earlier
today that the gun
that was recovered after the shooting
was ruth cox's gun
correct
do you recall in your report that you
had said a number of times that you
assumed it was mary haskins grey's gun
if i did it was a mistake i think it was
dr cox's gun
and i think if you can refer to page
nine
of your report
specifically halfway down the page
before the heading that says medical
reports yes
did you put in brackets there i believe
the gun was a pistol that belonged to ms
gray uh
i'm sorry it could be the reference
please yes sir it's uh page nine
the last line before the heading oh i
have it i think that was an error i
think that it belonged to dr cox
and on page 14.
did you indicate at the bottom of the
page
in the last paragraph he had in his
possession a small pink pistol which i
believe came from mary haskins again i
think that was an error um
i remembered clearly it was a pink
pistol
not to be sexist about it but it looked
like a quote woman's pistol and uh it uh
it belonged to one of the women and i
must have had that mixed up when i
dictated the report i i'm almost sure it
came from dr cox
so we don't have to go through the
exercise again would you agree with me
on page 17
if it says i'm not certain when he
obtained the small pink pistol which i
believe was owned by ms gray
that would be the same answer yeah i
think it was my error i think it was
just dr cox
were you aware from your review of the
discovery that there were multiple
places where it was referenced as ruth
cox's gun
i think so
you'd ever asked michael barason when he
first obtained that gun did you
well yes uh he he said that he obtained
it it had been locked up in a safe as i
recall and he obtained it shortly before
he uh went down to confront
um lauren cataract at where she was
living and he armed himself because he
was frightened for his life
and he as i recall he removed it from
his safe where it had been kept for
safekeeping can you show me or tell me
where in your report you put that
that
so your recollection is that you asked
michael barissone when he first obtained
the gun yes i might be able to find it
in my notes not in the report
or it might be in the police report i
don't remember
would you
take my word for it that it's not in
your report yes i will
so your recollection is that at some
point when you were interviewing michael
barissone
he told you that he remembered getting
the gun from the safe
before he went to the house yes
and at least for purposes of your
cross-examination you agree with me
that's not in your report i i'm not
gonna look through it and waste the
jury's time i'll accept your
representation
did you ask him when he first obtained
the gun from ruth cox
uh from what i recall
she had come up from north carolina to
visit
and uh she gave it to him for
safekeeping and he put it in this safe
would you agree with me that that's not
in your report either no that's not in
the report and as i recall i don't know
if it was a licensed weapon and i think
that for safe keeping he put it in his
safe
that's my best recollection of it
so your recollection from
reviewing the discovery and speaking to
michael barrasson
is that you knew that ruth cox had
brought the gun with her from north
carolina had given it to the defendant
for safekeeping he put it into his safe
he got it at some point before the
shooting before he went to the farmhouse
that's my best understanding yes and
none of that is in your report correct
and you continually attributed the gun
to ms greg throughout the course well
that was an error it was dr cox's gun
no further questions judge what
redirect
dr uh the prosecutor asked you uh
questions on cross with regards to
where you got the
statement
concerning
sexual abuse
allegations made to dcp correct yes
did you review the safe sport
complaint filed by lauren cataract i
never saw that complaint i was aware of
it through the police investigation but
i never saw the complaint
prosecutor asks you questions about
feigning what is fainting painting is
faking
okay and uh
did you consider
uh whether or not my client was feigning
based on
well it's always a consideration in a
forensic interview especially when the
stakes are high and feigning or
malingering which is another form of
fainting can be done for any number of
reasons it can be done in a simple civil
context where somebody feigns injuries
to get a reward say an insurance
settlement or something like that or
somebody can feign facts in a case to
avoid criminal responsibility so in
evaluating anybody feigning or
malingering is something which is always
a consideration okay and
in your consideration of that
did you find any evidence
based on everything that you did
to indicate that michael barrasson was
feigning about not remembering the event
i i hate the word annie because eddie is
like any
i don't know maybe he twitched his left
eye and that would be seen by some
people as evidence
if you're asking me did i find any
significant evidence that he was faking
the answer is no
nothing forever
well you may step down doctor thank you
thank you
thank you
i call your next witness dr paxton
[Music]
please remain standing left you're way
ahead of me left hand on a bible right
hand please listen to my court clerk do
you swing the presence of almighty god
that the testimony gives to this court
regarding this matter shall be the truth
the whole truth and nothing but the
truth i do please state your name and
spell your last name my name is charles
hassan
h-a-s-s-o-n thank you all right you may
have a seat doctor please keep your
voice up nice and loud go ahead mr
blanca's direct examination
good afternoon good afternoon
uh where do you currently decide
uh in
new jersey ridgefield new jersey
and what's your profession what do you
do for a living i'm a licensed
psychologist in new jersey and in new
york state and how long have you been a
licensed psychologist over 30 years
and uh
what's the difference between a
psychologist and a psychiatrist a
psychiatrist is an individual has an md
degree
a psychologist has a phd psychologist
doesn't prescribe medication the
difference in the two is in my opinion
the psychologist has more training in
therapy
and also in psychological testing the
psychiatrist more has a training in the
biological basis of mental illness
now can you give a brief uh description
of your educational background okay
well i received my bachelor's and my
master's degree in psychology
subsequently i went to boston college i
received a phd in educational psychology
during the time i was there
i did a
internship at a hospital new england
medical center
it was an interdisciplinary program with
four psychiatrists four psychologists
and four social workers
while at
boston college
well actually while at the tufts program
my supervisor
had just graduated from rutgers
university and did research on infant
memory
and i asked her if i could contact her
supervisor i did my dissertation on 11
week old babies
okay uh can you give us uh
your background with regards to any
agencies that you were affiliated with
uh with regards to your use of your
well for a number of years i worked i
did reports for hudson county superior
court approximately 1200 to 1500 reports
of a number of years i was working for
the rossi group at that time
subsequently i became an administrator
at hudson county jail
for three years
i saw patients i had my
office on the unit
they were all psychiatric patients there
during the time that i saw the patients
and treated them i also did further
reports for the superior court
i also did
work at a day hospital program for three
years for aggressive children i
developed the programs there
i also worked over 20 years for social
security disability
doing disability assessments they
involve psychiatric psychological memory
and concentration type of assessments
and um
i also work currently
at
a long-term care facility
in which i'm a neuropsychologist i
provide direct care and i also
go out and interview prospective
uh patients like at greystone and other
places
i'm part of a team with a mental health
director i'm the director i'm the
chief psychologist on the mental health
unit
there's two two units there for mental
health one with really severely impaired
individuals that have behavioral
problems many of them have dementia and
then there's other people who have like
schizophrenia schizoaffective disorder
and i work with them too and i also see
other patients throughout the building
have you ever worked for diapers yes i
have over what did you do for them i did
uh psychological assessments for diaphys
for a time i also work for the pru unit
that's the um the parents
attorneys
and then i also did some work for the
guardian ad litem
how about work for
either police or correctional officers
actually uh when i worked for the rossi
group
i did psychological assessments on law
enforcement they were
police
firemen and i also
did reports for
private
police departments if a police officer
was depressed or had some kind of
difficulties i made a recommendation
either to allow them to have their
weapon or have it taken away for period
of time
i also have done work for
different prosecutors offices and
private attorneys this last year i did a
report for passaic county prosecutor's
office on a cruel case
i appeared in court about three times
via a
video
and it was on a complicated crawl case
in the last two years i did
approximately nine private cases
including that one did you ever do any
uh
psychology work in the hudson county
jail well i was the administrator there
i was i was hired by a psychiatrist
i coordinated all treatment
on the unit i scheduled the psychiatric
care and as i said i had my
office right on the tier with the uh
the inmates
how many evaluations have you done
many thousands
of evaluations
so i would estimate anywhere between 8
000 and above
and
did most of those evaluation involved
psychological testing yes
have you ever testified as an expert yes
i have in federal and state court in new
jersey and out of state
for both
prosecutors offices and defense yes
judge at this point
i offer
dr hassan as an expert in psychology
prosecutor do you have any questions as
to the qualifications of dr hassan not
at this time judge i'll ask him
and do you have any objection to the
court qualifying him as an expert in the
area of psychology
all right based on the testimony of
dr hassan with regard to his education
his background his work history training
uh i do find that he's an expert in the
area of psychology pursuant to rule 702
of the new jersey rules of evidence and
he will be
permitted to render his opinion i do
find he does possess some specialized
knowledge that will assist the trier in
fact
in making determinations necessary in
this case
so qualified go ahead mr balencas
doctor
were you hired by the defense to do an
evaluation of michael barrasso yes
and
specifically
can you set forth what do you hire to do
well broadly speaking the goal was to
assess his mental state at the time of
the shooting on august 7 2019
but more specifically to determine
whether he suffered from
a mental disorder as referenced in the
diagnostic manual
which impaired his thinking to the
extent that he could not appreciate
um
uh
his actions
and if he didn't know what his actions
were did not know what he was doing was
wrong
he did not know the nature and quality
of his actions
did you
physically meet with michael barrasso
yes how many times i met with him seven
times
and uh did you put the dates
in your report as to when you
uh met with him yes
but are there any mistakes with regards
to the date
yes there are mistakes there i met with
him explain
when you met with him
and for how long i met with him on um
october 29th
november 5
november 6
november 19 november 20 december 4
december 5 for a total of 37 and three
quarter hours
in addition to meeting with michael
barristone for 37 plus hours
uh did you um
interview anyone else
i interviewed his
former
therapist
dr
picard
p-i-c-a-r-d i misspelled it on my report
all right and how long did you
interview her 45 minutes
i also reviewed some notes she sent me
including um text messages back and
forth between mr barisson and her over a
period of time
and and why did you feel it necessary to
interview
uh
mr picard cargo
well i wanted to find out
whether she had whether he had any uh
prior vulnerabilities
that would influence the possibility of
going from
an earlier psychological vulnerability
state into psychosis
now
why is that important to you
with respect to your evaluation
well there's a great deal of research
that shows that many people in the
general environment have what the
pre-psychotic features
and if they're placed in a very
stressful circumstance they could
convert into a psychotic
situation
in his case she said that
while he appeared to be
healthy strong
and
imposing six foot three or six foot four
she said he was a very vulnerable person
and that
he suffered from long-term
psychological problems including
depression suicidal thoughts
she noted that there was a time when he
was in europe
i think 2015 and 2016 in which he spoke
to her by telephone stating that he
had researched getting um
assisted suicide in switzerland for ten
thousand dollars and she was able to
talk him out of
the suicide attempt or not attempt the
actual suicide but she said that
basically um
he uh suffered from
a lot of emotional instability she
praised him as having good features of
his personality but at the same time she
gave a non-varnished opinion about him
saying you know he had good points and
some difficulties
do you reference your interview with uh
ricardo on page nine
yes
what if any other information
that was relevant to your evaluation did
you obtain from uh
she said basically that he was uh
paranoid on the fringes
uh i'm sure she didn't know the actual
term but it would be pre-psychotic she
had features of an individual who could
develop uh psychosis if he was placed
under sufficient amount of stress
and did she indicate anything with
regards to
his history as a
child small boy well he had a difficult
childhood um
he had a
rough upbringing with his mother who was
emotionally
abusive and also likely physically
abusive and he struggled
he made his uh he made a successful life
but you know he had a great deal of
difficulties he was also sexually
assaulted as a child
now what impact if any would those
circumstances have on your evaluation of
michael
will individuals who tend to convert
from pre-psychotic to a psychotic state
have those features of having emotional
instability having a childhood history
of abuse and also being sexually
assaulted
it would be a vulnerability that could
magnify the effects of outside pressures
did
miss picardo indicate the length of time
that she had treated michael barrasso
not at all she treated him on and off
for 20 years
she said approximately the last two
years she hadn't treated him but before
that she treated him for she treated him
six years earlier for about three years
straight
now
in addition to your
clinical interviews of michael barrosone
and
your interview of picardo who was
treating michael barrasson did you do
any psychological testing yes i did
personality
cognitive
neuropsychological but most important i
did validity testing divility testing
looked at personality test to see if
they were valid and also at cognitive
assessments to see if they were valid
such as memory
okay
with regards to the mmpi two of
what is that
mmpi 2 is an objective personality test
two false questions
and um
well there's a total of 567
and um two false questions
it's uh the it's
i did the mmpi two i scored that
and uh basically it has ten clinical
scales
uh each has a different name so what are
those clinical scales
measure they measure uh
psychological problems such as
depression anxiety schizophrenia mania
etc
and do each of those components look at
different aspects of someone's
personality yes they do
and again
so the jury understands
what are those ten separate areas that
are around well
the scales have different names but
scale one measures somatic complaints
physical complaints
scale two measures depression
scale 3 measures a concept called
hysteria scale 4 measures psychopathic
deviance
it sounds scary but it could be made up
of
family and emotional problems scale 5
measures of sex identification skill 6
measures paranoia scale 7 it's called
sarcastinia but it measures anxiety
scale 8 measures of thought disorder of
schizophrenia it's labeled scale 9
measures mania
the mean on the test the middle score is
50. if you go above 65 it's significant
every 10 points above that is a standard
deviation
and in this particular case
mr barrisson scored extremely high
on scale six he had a t-score of 90. and
what is tail six again
paranoia i'm sorry
and
it means that if we went in this whole
building
there would probably be uh
.001
people who scored as high as that it's
extremely rare but the important part
about that
is that the validity scales did not show
any feigning
it
was you mentioned the word validity
scales can you explain that so the jury
can understand what you're talking about
every test should have validity to see
whatever conclusions are made are
accurate if the test is um
doesn't have good validity scales it can
come up with any statement but on the
mmpi it's basically one of the gold
standards in the united states and in
the world
for uh testing personality he did not he
did not show feigning he answered
genuinely honestly and he had a very
high score
on paranoia
and then when i looked at the components
of paranoia persecutory ideas it's
called pa1 i believe the score was 105
if i'm not mistaken that's even higher
and what does that 90 score and that 105
score indicate to you as a psychologist
with regards to michael
barrison's mental state well not just to
me any psychologist who did work on the
um mmpi would look at that to say that
there is a very high likelihood of a
delusional disorder
a psychosis a break with reality
now how did you score that
test i ran it through a computer program
made by psychological corporation
i gave it what they call extended scores
and are there other ways to score that
test yes using that computer program you
could hand score it but it's best to do
the computer scoring then i looked at
additional
scales on there there's one
program by alexander caldwell
that is a ratio between neurotic
and psychotic
traits he had a high score on that an 88
score
that suggests
that he's very prone to making
idiosyncratic
uh unusual deductions about events in
the real world that would fit in with
being paranoid there's information out
there and he combines it in a way
that
uh doesn't make sense
and
that's all
data
and
scores that you got from the mmpi
yes paranoid anything else from the uh
from that specific test well he had a
high score on anxiety
and x he had a high score another score
on biz number two
that shows bizarre slightly bizarre
thinking there's different types of
delusional disorder he has a delusional
disorder two not a one one would be in
schizophrenia his type of delusion
is a a non-bizarre type of delusion
what's the difference can you explain
that to the jury what type of delusion
that test is pointing to
well a test would pick up both if he had
a high score on scale eight which is
schizophrenia and a high score on six it
would suggest that he has some type of
schizophrenia variation it would be a
type one delusional disorder but he
didn't have that
his the type two delusional disorder
like the schizophrenia type
you cannot make sense of why the
person's experiencing that but on a type
1
there's some event in the environment
that the person is experiencing and is
giving it an odd type of spin but
there's something out there that could
make sense to you so if you were in your
living room in your house and the people
above you are making noise
on one hand you could say well it's the
children front like a rang frolicking
around on the floor
on the other hand you could say that uh
someone has brought in some
super machinery that is making the noise
because they're trying to probe the
people underneath
you know and get secret information
so there's a noise out there but the way
that the person interprets it is off
now um did you score uh
michael barrasson with regards to the
raw shock ink walk test yes and can you
explain that test to the ladies and
gentlemen of the jury the rorschach game
plot test was developed in 1921 by
hermann rorschach it's um ten inkblots
initially was 41 inkbots but the
publisher didn't want to spend the money
so they just kept 10.
and it was a game in germany at the time
that
you would show the picture of inkblot
and ask the person what it is
in any event i scored it according to
one of the the current systems the exner
system
and basically came out showing that he
is uh emotionally unstable
um
he
has difficulty coping with stresses in
the world around him
part of the problem with his coping is
he switches from overly emotional to an
overly ideational or cognitive
way of handling it but he's not behaving
consistently so because he doesn't
behave consistently two things happen
the people in the environment can't time
figure him out how he's going to behave
and also because he's switching back and
forth he doesn't really work things out
you know to come to a conclusion
how is that horse shot that test scored
well you uh measure where
the person is shown a ink plot and you
say what might this be and then after
that you ask them where on the inkblot
they saw it then you asked them what
about it made it look like a bat so they
may say it's the the form
it's dark ink or black or something like
that
and you score that the determinants so
you score the determinants for form
color movement
and um
and there's a whole bunch of other
variables there
you know on that you can score
so um
how reliable is that test doctor well
it's not like the mmpi how however it's
it's good in terms of
explaining a person's way they see the
world around them their perception and
their cognition
but it's it's not meant to um
uh
find out if a person has a delusional
disorder because she could be the
unobama right and come up with a very
clean profile
you know because the person could say
well i saw a bat over here i saw this uh
that over there but it doesn't really
speak to the issue of
of uh the way he's thinking
is there any validity
um
portion of that test uh
to determine its accuracy well if you're
going to do that test you have to do it
to a t you just can't do it you know
partially
and
the the idea behind all of the testing
is you do a whole host of testing to see
if there's an overlap or agreement in
the diff different tests so you don't
hang your hat on the mmpi alone although
that's a strong test
and you don't hang your hat on anything
else but to see if there's coherence
there was coherence
uh between the rorschach and these other
tests that i did the rorschach indicated
another quality of mr um
michael uh was that um he has uh a
tendency to put together various pieces
of information that are discombobulated
and form it together to come up with an
idea it's over inclusive thinking and i
found that when i spoke with them
and i also found that on other testings
now
other than the mmpi
did you do any other psychological
testing i gave another test called the
pai personality assessment inventory and
what is that
uh
that's a
test similar
to the mmpi but it's different
technically
and
but it's a it's a solid test uh the
validity scales were within normal
limits
i used rogers uh there's a famous
american
psychologist who's done has done a lot
of the work on malingering and deception
i used his cut scores
for that test
and it was not it was genuine the way he
responded
the summon substance of that test was he
was high on
paranoid thinking
ideas of persecution and he showed
effective instability the effect of
instability was picked up by
a possible um
diagnosis of borderline
personality disorder but that's neither
here nor there the main point is that he
had effective instability where his
emotions can be discombobulated kind of
quickly under pressure
did you do any validity testing well it
has validity testing on it on there
one is called the ni
what validity testing within a test
deals with validity testing
can determine if an individual
is manipulating his responses whether
he's overly reporting pathology or under
pathology
it can tell that right give an example
so the jury can understand
well uh suppose like i'm trying to um
there's no diagnosis of malinger
but suppose i'm trying to feign
uh some
fake what you're saying fake if i'm
trying to fake something that test could
pick it up
and how does it do that uh it has scales
that have been uh over the years
been uh
determined to pick show that right
so uh some some scales can pick up
whether a person is
claiming excessive amount of uh positive
characteristics that most of the people
in the
world will not
claim like i never lose my temper
there's other things that uh there's
other ways to do that but the pai
the mmpi have the strongest validity
scales
did you do any other validity testing
yes what
i did a test called the service too
sirs-2
it's
a revamping of service one
what they wanted to do is to cut down on
false positives so if someone was let's
say feigning amnesia or something like
that or fainting some psychiatric
condition they don't want to have false
positives so what a false positive is if
you go into a jail there's a
magnetometer and every time you go
through it if it rings makes a buzz
because you have a back problem you had
surgery metal in your back
that has a high sensitivity
but
it has
it's not a specific
you're not bringing in a gun or anything
like that so rogers and his associates
when they developed it they wanted to
have a test that had strong specificity
so that you wouldn't get false positives
on that particular test
um
barrisone did not show any feigning he
scored um
honestly
any other validity testing well there
was two others i did two other uh
personality tests they look at
personality from a different perspective
why did you look at a personality test
in evaluating
well for the simple reason if you're a
forensic psychologist or psychiatrist or
whoever it might be you want to make
sure that you're not being misled having
your own biases you want to look look at
the person you're interacting with and
you don't want to
be skewed in a certain direction so i
like to do a lot of testing to see if
i'm missing something so the tests have
leading scales i might say well someone
is uh perfectly you know well or not and
if the testing is comes out in a
different way i have to scratch my head
and look more deeply
uh did you do any personality tests
um
and
if so what specific tests did you do
well as i mentioned i did uh the mmpi
the rorschach the pai they all look at
abnormal
aspects of personality but i wanted to
compare it
to other tests that look at normal
personality
because why did you want to look at that
because i i wanted to check on my own
views to see if i was accurate to see if
these other tests were accurate that's
called construct validity i wanted to
check it out what does that mean explain
that to the jury
well
there's a concept in psychology called
multi-trait matrix and what that means
is you want to give multiple measures
from different situations and to see if
they all agree with each other right if
there's agreement you can say well you
know what that may be an accurate uh
uh finding
and so it's a check i do the testing as
a check on myself and also a check on
the test the two other tests that i gave
measure normal traits if you have an
excess
or
a low amount of a certain trait it can
cause psychological problems those two
tests agreed with the mmpi and the pai
and also the rorschach
basically um
on the uh 16 pf it's um
it's developed on a person a
factor analysis approach but anyway
there were four ele four elevations on
that test if i'm recalling you know
clearly
one was called uh q4 is a very high
level of anxiety and depression another
was a very low score on c
um this test divides
all of the scores in tents
there's ten one two three there's ten of
them
if you have a a score of one or a score
of 10 that's a very uh elevated score
either way
now the score that on c
was
emotional instability he had a score of
one which is similar to the rorschach
and similar to the other tests that he's
unstable emotionally he could be
emotionally upset
a little more easily than other people
and did the tests that you've
testified to so far
all
coincide with each other as far as the
bottom line results yeah they did and
what does that tell you from a
practitioner's standpoint emotionally
unstable
other tests
indicate that he could easily be moved
into a
psychotic state psychotic stages to
break with reality
and
some of the tests show that he has very
idiosyncratic thinking
the rorschach showed the over-inclusive
thinking it's a technical term but all
it simply means that if you meet with uh
michael barrasson you're talking with
him it's really hard to do a clinical
interview with him because he's all over
the place
so um
anyway yeah uh
did you do any cognitive tests yes i did
and again why would you do a cognitive
test in a
psychiatric evaluation because when i
came in and i tried to interview him and
uh and by the way the reason i did it
over seven sessions
was
it's very hard for someone to play act
over a long period of time if you see
someone who's play acting there's a
movement towards normality
as time goes on because it's hard to
keep up the act there was no change with
him he was uh crying sobbing at one
point
um the office who was outside he he
called me over and said are you okay
because he heard him like uh ranting and
raving he was very upset
and um because of that i suspect that he
had some kind of problem you know
neurologically or with attention or
whatever it might be so i decided to
investigate that okay and is that why
you did cognitive tests yes what
specific cognitive test did you do well
first i gave a full iq test because it
could tell you if he has deficits in
certain areas
the test is called the wechsler
intelligence scale and there's a part on
it that measures verbal abilities
non-verbal ability working memory where
you could do two things at the same time
um
whistle and uh you know play guitar i'm
being facetious but it measures uh two
cognitive things at the same time second
motor speed and it also gives a
full-scale iq
i gave that i found out that on that
testing he has a problem with uh working
memory it's a variation of attention and
uh then i also checked out
his
verbal iq is up here
and his working memory is over here it's
20 points lower you know what does that
tell you
it's a relative deficit
in working memory attention
um and how does that relate to your
evaluation
and i also asked him about his childhood
he said that he always had trouble
maintaining focus in school right but i
noticed that when he'd be talking to me
he would be repeating himself
constantly as if like he couldn't
remember what he just said
and then he'd be all over the place
and it was very hard to keep up with him
so the way i did it was i ignored
any extra talk and i wrote down
phrase by phrase and then when i came
back to it i said well you just said
such and such and i continue that way it
was a little bit more tedious but i can
get a comprehensive
um interview done with him
now because i saw that there was a
problem with working memory and aspects
of attention
so like for example
if you say to him give me digits forward
he could do pretty well on that
five or seven between five and seven
digits forward
and then i said dude backwards
like um two four he's supposed to say
four two he could only do three for
someone who's as intelligent he's an
intelligent person intelligent as him it
was a low score
so then i looked at um attention and i
gave one test um
to check out attention and uh his school
is
uh the uh cpt the kane's continuous
performance test
and
he scored so low
on it i was surprised so i gave it to
him three times and he scored as if he
was neurologically impaired with an
intentional problem
or you know a diagnosis of adhd
then i wasn't i didn't stand on that
test alone
so i also gave another test called the
act
it's a auditory consonant test so it's
something like this
you say to the person
three consonants like i'm just making
this up a b c
and then you say 200 and the person has
to count backwards by threes
200 197 194 191 all the way back then
you get to either 9 or 18 or 36 seconds
you say what were the three words
and uh
usually a person would say abc with
michael he scored at the first in the
second percentile level it was a low
score they know
he has an intentional problem he's all
over the place he's like scattered
the scattered quality has i started
picking up when i was talking with him
he'd be uh saying to me wait a minute i
got to tell you this i got to tell you
that and his thoughts
were not linear it wasn't like he was
following you know in a way that i could
follow easily it was difficult you know
to follow and what could cause
someone to score or react like that well
it's it's hard to say 100 percent
because he has um had a fracture of the
skull when he was age eight
he also had eight to twelve uh
concussions falling from a horse
uh dr picardo
uh mentioned to me that he also fell
when he was roofing his house and she
said that
he was too macho to want to go into the
hospital
he used to do a lot of construction
around his property
but
it could be from the fall it could be uh
some other developmental problem right i
don't know but he has he has an
intentional problem and his thoughts are
scattered
okay and uh
in reviewing the discovery
did you review the injury
that michael barrasson suffered in this
incident yes
and
what if any impact
could they have had on his
neuropsychological testing
well
he has no memory for the incident
and in my report i noted a reputable
neuropsychiatrist cummings from
california he gave two examples he said
that gene tony who was a price fighter
who fought against dempsey he dropped
out of boxing
because he started having
amnesia periodic bouts of amnesia and
then and the doctor gave the uh an
example of another price fighter who was
fighting a fight and from the fourth
round on he didn't even know he won the
fight until hours later he had to be
told
so he was uh
to me he looked like he lost the mixed
martial art fight he had
severe bruising in his face
he had
bleeding under the left ear i think
bleeding from the right eye
and
he looked like he had was given a
workout now it's possible
that the uh the beating you know
affected his memory i can't say 100
percent
but
um
it may have impaired what they call
consulate consolidation
you know
but
would his previous
head injuries that you mentioned
uh
impact on a subsequent uh have an impact
on subsequent yes because if you look
you feel like a price fighter and you
get beaten a lot of times
um let's say later in life you hit your
head it could uh have more of an impact
than if it was the first time the more
prior blows to the head especially in
the front of the face or wherever you
got hurt
it's going to have a greater impact than
just one beating
now
did you test for executive functions yes
what are executive functions well
the executive functions i i look i try
to look at it like differently
executive functions are like
organization uh planning
things of that sort he scored well on
that i also gave him a test among the
executive functions that picks up if
there's some form of brain damage either
acute or diffuse he didn't have any
problems with that the only thing that i
did notice in terms of executive
functions you know and i uh
i looked at it is that
he has some kind of nonverbal visual
problem
and like if you ask him to draw a
pattern a complex pattern he doesn't
draw the outside he draws like a little
bit of it it's as as as if he has
trouble forming a visual picture of
something i don't know if that's from
it's unusual i don't know if that's from
the uh head trauma or what
but
um people who tend to have some kind of
executive dysfunction sometimes when
they
uh try to do a task they don't organize
it his was like all over the place in
that regards
any other tests all right so um because
he claimed that he had amnesia for the
event first of all i also wanted to do
uh validity testing so the most
important validity testing for cognitive
is the vip
and it showed uh no uh feigning on
either when you say validity testing
you administered a specific test
to determine whether or not
michael barra batterstone was
feigning
faking faking
not remembering the event
i wanted to see because people who are
feigning they typically try to claim all
manner
of uh memory impairment they overplay
their hand
he didn't do that his memory was not not
terrible or anything of that sort
and on the um the vip
it came out that he was honest and
genuine except i have to say this
on one part of the vip is a non-verbal
part it indicated there's a computer
program on there that had trouble
maintaining his attention on a
non-verbal on the non-verbal part of the
test
but even with that it came out that he
was conclusively
genuine in how he responded he showed
effort and intent to do well on that
test and what is that uh have to do with
your opinion as to whether or not he's
fainting
he wasn't feigning memory impairment and
if he's claiming that he can't remember
you know i
um
i tend to buy what he's saying except
that i don't know if it's
uh from um psychogenic i put down this
dissociative amnesia from stress but it
could be from the beating it could be
from the uh prior head injuries or what
so
it could be either
from a physical injury or from a mental
yes
and if i might interject i just wrote a
recent review article
that it was uh from a university in uh
holland
that on
the program is like criminology there
and they studied
20 years of worldwide
claims of dissociative disorder they
looked at the um the studies themselves
and the problem is that the people who
did the studies they didn't rule out tbi
a lot of people had like what's tbi uh
traumatic brain injury they had mild
traumatic brain injury and they didn't
real rule that out as the reason the
person couldn't remember
so in his case i put down that he had an
emotional type of loss of memory
but
he also had you have to keep in mind
that he had a beating
did you do any memory tests
yes i did and um and why did you do a
memory test when you were evaluating
michael barry's own state of mind at the
time of the incident well i want to
first of all i wanted to see if he had
some kind of significant brain damage
that can influence the results and like
i just said that people who are feigning
amnesia or memory impairment
they tend to overplay their hand
so they have memory impairment all over
the place
his actually was very specific in one
little area and that was non-verbal
memory
and were there any validity
portions of those tests
well the validity was the vip i also did
another test called the cvlt and i also
did another test called the tom the cvlt
is a list learning test
and it has a validity component built
into it the bottom line is that he was
not feigning on
that test on the tom which is non-verbal
memory
uh recognition memory he had a poor
school
i i didn't know whether it was from the
fact that he had problem with non-verbal
memory
or what
but you know
uh he was given four tests three out of
the four came out fine that the the vip
is the most powerful one
of those different tests
fine
he was not uh feigning
did you do any perceptual tests
i did
which ones
uh well the tests that i gave were from
the um the nab
uh that's the neuropsychological
assessment battery so you have a whole
bunch of tests on that then i
supplemented that with some other tests
that i gave i gave a test called the ray
complex figure test on that test i saw
that he he worked very piecemeal in
terms of putting things together
he also has a memory component on that
he scored poorly in terms of memory for
non-verbal
um his perceptual functioning was
borderline in a couple of tests i don't
know if
you know if i did more
assessment with them which i thought was
like uh
i didn't see the utility of it but you
know maybe i could determine exactly
what the problem is with the non-verbal
functioning
and finally did you do uh any tests with
respect to language i did
and why would you
test
or give him language because you have a
beating to your front of your head and
this like the frontal area of the skull
it could damage your verbal production
so if you say to an individual i'm gonna
give you uh 60 seconds and tell me as
many words that begin with the letter f
a
f i s first with f don't give me
people's names like fernando don't give
me places like france don't give me
numbers like five
and you total it up there's um
tables that are based on age education
ethnicity and he scored uh very fine
average score is between 12 to 15 words
per minute and he was like 18
18 per minute so
from the beating he had it didn't affect
that language production area
okay now
you've testified to a great number of
tests that you administered um were they
were the tests consistent with each
other
the tests were consistent in showing no
feigning
no feigning on personality or cognitive
and
what else
did the test
indicate to you based on your score the
test didn't the test indicate that he
suffers from a paranoia delusional
disorder
of a very high uh
level
and that uh it's very significant
all right
now did you
review dr simmering's evaluation yes i
did and did you review that stack of uh
91 pages that were provided yes i put
down 51 but i don't know exactly what
the number is for the simple reason i
did count 91 but then i noticed
in the pages themselves that there were
duplicates
so i didn't actually
count the clean pages so i don't know if
it's 51 77 or 91 the total that i went
through was 91
but there's duplicates in there okay
now
did you review any uh discovery that was
provided by the prosecutors yes i went
over the police reports morris county
uh department's reports
of the hospital reports
the emt reports the emergency room
reports the orthopedic reports
did you review any
social media oh yes
this was rough because there were like
six boxes of facebook uh post like over
twenty thousand i look i went through a
number of them
but um
i didn't record all
that i went through on my list but
uh there's one
box uh for uh mr goodwin i think it's um
2000 or so
uh items
i also went over uh text messaging back
and forth between different parties
now
with regards to the uh social media
posts did you talk to michael barriston
about
various posts that he saw
that lauren cataract posted
about him yes
and
did you discuss any post where she
talked about uh going to war yes
and and
what if any impact
did
those posts have on michael barrasso
well he's calm right now but when i was
talking with him he was like petrified
he was frightened
when he read and i read it i read him
the post to see what he was what it was
like you know how he reacted he was
frightened
um did you go over
a post where cataract talked about uh
weapons guns yes and also saw pictures
she had
of uh and what specific
effect
did that have on michael barrasson he
was super frightened he remained super
frightened
on one of the times that i was there
when i was leaving he said to me that
he wanted to judge if he was freed
objection judge
don't say anything about the judge i'll
move on
okay questions withdrawn
in the discovery that she reviewed
did you discuss
the fact that lauren cataract was tape
recording michael paracel yes and did
you discuss
what impact
that recording was having on his mental
state
he was incredibly frightened
he had no refuse no place to go where he
felt safe
and uh he was very upset he said uh this
is an example of a terrorist you know
and um
he was uh frightened
you know tremendous amount
and it upset him
that um
she had a post that
she referred to him and the other people
there scurrying around
going into their car
you know to
to speak to each other but he was just
very frightened
what impact does
someone thinking whether it's true or
not
that every word that you say
is being listened to
judge i'm going to object to the general
nature of the question
yeah i think it's a little boring
rephrase it please
um
what effect did
michael barrows own think
thinking that every word that he spoke
to anyone
was being recorded by someone that he
was afraid of it made him super paranoid
super paranoid that everything he was
doing was being monitored not only being
recorded he thought that he was being
filmed
did you revoke review posts with him
where um lauren cataract was telling
people on facebook of facebook that
michael barrasson was uh threatening her
life
that super super frightened him super
because he has distorted thinking so
here's what his thinking was like he
said to me that um
the parkland shooting person
stated that he was bullied then he said
kanarak said
she's bullied
so then he said my conclusion is she's
going to kill me just like the parkland
shooter
he that's how he his deduction was off
but that's what he
how we came up with that
and
did you discuss with him
numerous contacts that he made with
people
who cataract had previously
posted things on facebook about yes
for instance the name staggered and
parkinson i remember that okay now
i don't want you to say
what those posts contained
but you did did you discuss those posts
with michael barrasso yes
and
what did he say about those posts and
what was their effect on his mental
state well the effect was it made him
even more uh frightened
he saw how
other people were treated
and he thought that there was a greater
danger
actually admitted that to me so i asked
him about like you know
how
things transpired to cause him all this
difficulty and he says well it was
the pattern
of everything that came his way
he looked up he got information on
cataract her behavior and everything
together made him
more more frightened
but he felt as if there was a realistic
threat out there
now
did you discuss with him him leaving his
residence
a week or so before
the
um the incident yes
and
what did he indicate to you was the
reason that he left
he feared for his life
who we see living there with
with mary haskins
and uh i think for a time her son
and where did he uh go after he fled his
residence he went to the um
uh rec um i don't know if it's the
proper term the recreation room
at the stable there's a large room that
was furnished
um that had a kitchen area there and
place to sleep
and he moved in there
now a reception area that's what it was
called
did
did michael barrisson uh based on your
discussions with him
and the discovery that he reviewed
take any steps to try to protect himself
he was frightened he he felt as if uh
when he'd be talking to either mary
haskins or someone else
that
uh cataract was quoting directly
what he was saying
and uh he was he got more and more
scared you know
and what he did was he hired someone to
sweep um the barn area
and uh to see if they could find any of
the tape recorders
i'm going to show you d700-2
did you review this in your uh
discovery yes i did
what is that
this is a contract for debugging it's i
think
five thousand dollars
and um
of the
a certain area of the
barn um did michael barzone hire uh
anyone else
well he hired
a person to um
watch overnight
and to sit in his suv
because he was fearful
because he was saying that uh lauren
canorack and rob goodwin they'd be
wandering around at night
in the middle of the night and it was
fearful that they were going to do
something
do what burn the barn down harm people
and uh he when he stayed at the
reception area he made sure that all the
windows and doors were locked
did he do any other
anything anything else to protect
himself
um
did he hire a private oh yes yes yes he
hired a private investigator to find out
if they had a prior arrest record and
that upset him too
because he saw we
you cannot go okay specifics but
700 8-1
is this the
background check
that you talked to michael barrasson
about yes
and
can you tell the jury what impact
michael barissone getting this document
from the private investigator had on his
mental state
it intensified the fear the fear factor
he felt as if
there was a whole bunch of information
that was pointing the direction that
these are dangerous people
did michael barrasson ever call the
police yes you did
approximately how many times
approximately four times
and
did you discuss those specific instances
with them yes i did
and what did he indicate to you with
regards to each and every one of those
instances total frustration
uh he was trying to say how scared he
was
he felt as if they were poo pooing it
and he had no place to turn that's how
he felt he had no recourse and what did
that do to his psychic
he felt alone he felt vulnerable if you
know he felt as if uh
he felt as if he couldn't fight back so
to speak
and and
at some point was he told that the
morris county prosecutor's office
was
consulted yes
and
did anything happen with regards to them
consulting about this incident based on
your review of the discovery
the ap reviewed
um the information that uh michael found
upsetting
and they didn't find it of sufficient uh
um type to uh
follow through with any kind of action
it basically told him uh that it was a
landlord-tenant difficulty
and when michael barrisson heard that
both from the police and the
prosecutor's office
what effect did it have on him
felt more vulnerable he had no
protection
now
did michael barrasson talk to you about
his knowledge
of goodwin and canarax drug
use yes
i'm not going to ask you specifics
but did that play any role in michael
barrissone's mental state with regards
to
your evaluation yes he felt both how so
he felt both of them
were unstable to begin with and they
thought with the drug use that they're
even before even more unstable
and then
if i recall correctly he spoke to
someone who thought that drugs might be
planted on his vehicle and he got even
more scared
and
in addition to that information
did you talk to michael barissone about
warren cataract
posting things on social media
indicating that she had
mental
or psychological problems yes
did you discuss that with michael i did
and what impact did that have on his
mental state everything was drip drip
drip of making him more frightened
and
he particularly was frightened when she
essentially said
that she had multiple personalities and
she could not be responsible then he
combined that with images he saw of her
where there were gun images
statements that you made about shooting
at uh people who tried to um
objection just okay
all right sustained mr velenkus has
previously discussed
now
did michael barriston talk to you about
an incident where
robert goodwin made
some gesture with his uh finger
yes what specifically did he tell you
about that he said on august 6th
when the people from washington township
came to his place it was like three
different people
a number of cars
that came up
he said rob goodwin was 15 feet away and
he placed his hand in the form of a gun
to his head
and uh said more to the effect watch out
or something like that
and he smiled on his face
and um what did michael barriston say
about that smile to you he said it
scared him because she remembered um
something that happened long long time
ago when he was a little boy
he was sexually assaulted by someone and
he says oh i saw the same kind of eyes
the frightening eyes they scared him the
same thing when he had trouble with his
mother when she burnt his hand
it was the same kind of eyes
and he it made him frightened he was it
was just fearful of them
now
did you review the
police reports with regards to the day
of the incident yes
and and
did you re view the reports regarding
dcpp's contact with mary haskins and and
michael barrisson yes
now what did michael barrasson tell you
with regards to
um
what he heard
during that meeting with bcpp the only
thing i thought he said
that he heard the word of sexual abuse
and that he was worried that the
family would be broken up the children
taken away
and
he had a distorted view
that if the children were taken if he
and mary haskins were arrested his
biggest fear
which is this is completely delusional
his biggest fear
i think is delusional his biggest fear
was that um
lauren kanarak and rob goodwin
would kill the children
and he linked it up with seeing some
posts
where they were
trying to get information on the two
children
but he was frightened judge objection
there's no evidence of that
see inside more
we'll see you in about 15 minutes you
can step down doctor okay
you